dès que nous vous proposons un
déshabillons-les spécial cécile duflot
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre aujourd'hui sur notre
antenne l'examen du projet de loi
relatif à la poste c'est à suivre sur
public sénat à partir de 18h30
mais avant cela je vous propose de
suivre la lecture des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire du projet de
loi relatifs au transport ferroviaire
ce texte prévoit la transposition d'une
directive européenne qui doit permettre
l'ouverture à la concurrence du
transport international de voyageurs
mais ce qu'il va falloir suivre cet
après-midi ce sont les différentes
interventions des sénateurs socialistes
ils ont décidé de s'inscrire pour
prendre la parole sur cette commission
mixte paritaire pour retarder à l'examen
du projet de loi relatif à la poste tout
de suite dans direction l'hémicycle
bonne après midi à tous sur public sénat
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi relatif à
l'organisation et à la régularisation
des transports ferroviaires et guider et
portant diverses dispositions relatives
au transport dans la discussion générale
la parole et à monsieur francis grignon
rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
bonjour
seul président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous fait ainsi donc
parvenu au terme d'un long processus
législatif qui ait débuté pour le sénat
en octobre 2008 avec une science
publique qui s'est déroulée en février
mars de cette année qui s'est poursuivie
à l'assemblée nationale en septembre
la commission mixte paritaire sur le
projet de loi relatif à l'organisation
et à la régulation des transports
ferroviaires et portant diverses
dispositions relatives aux transports
s'est réuni mardi dernier à l'assemblée
nationale et j'ai aujourd'hui l'honneur
le plaisir de vous présenter les
principales conclusions de cette
commission
mais avant toutes choses permettez moi
de vous remercier monsieur le président
de la commission de l'économie du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire du sénat
notre collègue jean paul emorine mais
aussi christian jacob président de la
commission du développement durable de
l'assemblée nationale qui a d'ailleurs
présidé avec le président et maureen les
travaux de la commission mixte paritaire
je voudrais également féliciter monsieur
yannick paternotte rapporteur de
l'assemblée nationale dont les
préoccupations en matière de
développement de fret ferroviaire
rejoignent celles du sénat nous auront
d'ailleurs l'occasion sénat d'examiner
en détail la problématique du fret à
travers un rapport d'un groupe de
travail que votre commission de
l'économie du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire sera aura
à produire vraisemblablement au cours du
printemps de l'année prochaine
mes chers collègues le travail
parlementaire a permis d'enrichir de
manière substantielle le texte du projet
de loi puisque nous sommes passés de 25
à 53 articles à l'issue de la procédure
d'urgence rappelons brièvement les
quatre grands axes du projet de loi
premier axe il s'agit de mettre la
france en conformité avec les
dispositions des premier et troisième
paquet ferroviaire
parmi les mesures prévues figurent
l'autorisation du cabotage international
de voyageurs à partir du 13 décembre
autrement dit tout entre
rice ferroviaire qui exploite des
services de transport international de
voyageurs pour demain du mois après le
13 décembre
si elle le souhaite assurer des
dessertes intérieures en france à la
condition expresse que l'objet principal
du service soit le transport de
voyageurs entre les gares situées dans
les états membres différents de l'union
européenne et que cette activité ne
porte pas atteinte à l'équilibré
économique d'un contrat de service
public
ce point est important nous l'avons bien
sûr interpréter à l'assemblée au sénat
lé nationale pardon comme senna que cet
objet principal de service correspond à
peu près 75 à 80% de l'activité et non
pas comme certains puristes voudrait
l'évoqué à 50,00 1%
deuxième axe il convient d'instituer une
autorité de régulation des activités
ferroviaires qui sera en quelque sorte
le gendarme du réseau ferroviaire
national afin d' organiser la
concurrence entre les entreprises de
fret ferroviaire qui existe déjà et deux
mâts entre les entreprises de transport
de voyageurs il était en effet
indispensable de créer une autorité
indépendante qui veillera à ce que
l'accès aux capacités d'infrastructure
sur le réseau soit accordé de manière
équitable et non discriminatoire
l'autre la raf c'est ainsi que nous
l'avons appelé devra aussi donner et
c'est important un avis conforme sur les
péages qui sont qui constitue la
rénumération de réseau ferré de france
concernant l'avis motivé de la
commission européenne adhérer c'est à
notre pays il ya quelques semaines nous
avons lucie même ce jeudi 27 octobre un
débat avec la commission des affaires
européennes et monsieur le secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports sur ce
sujet et je crois pouvoir dire que les
dispositions du présent projet de loi
répond très largement aux préoccupations
de la commission
le troisième axe de groupe du texte
pardon regroupe diverses mesures
relatives à la route
d'une part il s'agit d'aménager le
régime juridique
de certaines concessions routières
relatives entre autres au tunnel sous le
mont blanc d'autre part sur le modèle
justement du cabotage international de
voyageurs par train
le texte permet aux poids lourds
internationaux de marchandises
d'effectuer sous de strictes conditions
les prestations sur le territoire
français naturellement l'état devra
mettre en oeuvre tous les moyens de
contrôle dont il dispose pour s'assurer
que cette mesure ne crée pas une
concurrence déloyale pour les
transporteurs de notre pays
il a été à cet effet que suggérer des
carnets de route à souche avec des
numéros bien identifiés nous verrons
enfin le dernier axe a trait à
l'aviation civile et poursuit plusieurs
objectifs
le texte du projet de loi redéfinit la
mission d'équipage
la durée le régime de travail du
personnel navigant de l'aéronautique
civile en outre il modifie les règles de
représentativité syndicale des
personnels navigants techniques afin de
tirer les conséquences de la loi de 2008
portant rénovation de la démocratie
sociale et réforme du temps de travail
sur ces questions essentielles j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que le parlement a
trouvé la voie du consensus entre les
principales organisations syndicales
représentatives
voilà brièvement rappelé la philosophie
de ce projet de loi le texte caille
borel qui a élaboré la commission mixte
paritaire n'a finalement avorté que deux
modifications essentiellement
rédactionnelles par rapport au texte
issu des débats de l'assemblée nationale
l'une portant sur l'article 23 cette
pièce relatifs aux contrats de
déménagement l'autre relative à
l'article 26 bis et concernant les
volumes de protection environnementale
si nous avons aujourd'hui un texte qui
s'éloignent peu du texte élaboré par les
députés c'est principalement parce que
nos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
n'ont pas remis en cause
les principaux rapports du sénat et que
les dispositions qu'ils ont ajouté au
texte étaient pertinentes et bienvenus
j'aimerais néanmoins pour conclure
évoqué l'article 2 bis à qui n'a pas été
remis en cause en commission mixte
paritaire relative à la ratp et au
syndicat des transports d'île de france
introduit à l'assemblée nationale par
voie d'amendement gouvernemental qui a
suscité bien des interrogations
je dois avouer au préalable qui lui
était préférable d'examiner ces
dispositions très importante en février
dernier au sénat plutôt que les
découvrir en commission mixte paritaire
je souhaite à l'avenir que le
gouvernement s'attache autant que
possible à anticiper les transposition
des directives et la bonne application
des règlements communautaires sur le
fond maintenant cet amendement je tiens
à déclarer très très clairement que les
choix retenus sont tout à fait
justifiées que les inquiétudes et les
craintes exprimées ici et là sont
infondées quels sont les objectifs
poursuivis par cet article finalement il
y en a deux d'une part aménagé
intelligemment la fin du monopole des
opérateurs historiques dans le domaine
du transport public en région ile de
france
ainsi les contrats en cours conclut avec
les entreprises de transport par bus
poursuivront maximum pendant 15 ans à
compter de l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
cette période étant porté à 20 ans pour
le tram haut et 30 pour le métro et le
rer exploitée par la ratp je précise à
cette occasion que tous les projets de
constructions nouvelles lignes seront
soumis à des appels d'offres ouverts à
la concurrence ce qui sera de paris
l'une des villes les plus concurrentiels
en europe sur cette question
d'autre part le deuxième objectif de cet
article est de répartir les actifs entre
la ratp et le stif en contrepartie du
transfert de matériel roulant de la ratp
vers le stif la régie se voit confier
comme mission de gérer l'ensemble du
réseau d'infrastructures de transport
francilien cet échange équilibré tout à
fait pertinents
car il garantit l'unité de gestion de ce
réseau et protège la capacité d'emprunt
du stif sur les marchés financiers voilà
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai les
éléments que je souhaitais mettre en
exergue
en définitive la commission mixte
paritaire élaborer un texte équilibré
qui a pleinement pris en compte les
souhaits du gouvernement incite le
préoccupations des députés des sénateurs
c'est pourquoi mes chers collègues je ne
peux que vous inviter à le voter
merci monsieur gagnant la parole et à
monsieur benoist apparu secrétaire
d'état chargé du logement et de
l'urbanisme monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole
le président ce président de la
commission mais c'est le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je tiens tout d'abord à excuser
dominique bussereau qui n'a pu être là
aujourd'hui
ils représentent en effet la france en
syrie pour défendre nos intérêts sur la
réalisation du métro de damas et pour le
port de lattaquié
nous voilà arrivés mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs au terme de notre parcours
législatif sur la loi relative à
l'organisation et à la régulation des
transports ferroviaires et portant
diverses dispositions de transport je
tiens en premier lieu à remercier le
travail approfondi fourni par votre
haute assemblée et plus particulièrement
par votre commission des affaires
économiques
et bien évidemment notamment son
président jean paul emorine et votre
excellent rapporteur francis grignon
je pense que cette loi restera une étape
importante dans le domaine des
transports
elle traite en effet des transports
ferroviaires et guider des transports
urbains des transports routiers des
transports aériens et de l'école de la
marine marchande
il ne m'entend fang le manque en fait
que le transport fluvial
pour être complet cette loi permettra à
notamment de transposer dans la
législation française
plusieurs directives et règlements
européens et notamment le rapporteur
vient de l'évoquer
le troisième paquet ferroviaire grâce à
elle la france va se mettre en
conformité avec les exigences
européennes
comme vous l'avez expliqué dominique
bussereau le 22 octobre dernier ici même
qu'apporte cette loi elle poursuit
d'abord le processus d'ouverture
progressive à la concurrence des
transports
initié il ya quelques décennies sous
l'impulsion de l'union européenne cette
ouverture a d'abord concerné le
transport routier puis le transport
aérien et elle s'exerce dans le domaine
ferroviaire de marchandises depuis le 31
mars 2006 il ne s'agit pas pour nous de
nous cacher derrière l'union européenne
qui nous imposerait une concurrence que
nous serions contraints de subir
je crois profondément aux avantages de
la concurrence
pour le développement des transports
elle profitera à ses clients aux
chargeurs comme aux voyageurs de fait
qui peut nier par exemple que c'est
grâce à la concurrence pour le transport
aérien que ce dernier devenu accessible
à tous et qu'il n'est plus réservé à une
clientèle d'affaires
cette concurrence a incité les
compagnies aériennes à trouver des modes
d'exploitation plus efficace comme les
par exemple qui offre aux clients un
maximum de choix de destinations et
c'est également cette concurrence qui
nous aura permis d'amener de
l'innovation au travers du modèle low
cost de la même manière le transport
ferroviaire de fret a bénéficié de
l'ouverture à la concurrence avant bien
évidemment que la crise économique
actuelle ne viennent brutalement le me
frapper en allemagne en grande-bretagne
aux pays-bas
la concurrence du transport de
marchandises a entraîné une hausse
sensible des trafics
aujourd'hui en france fait entreprises
ferroviaires autre que la sncf circule
d'ores et déjà sur notre réseau ferré
national
leur part de marché s'est déjà
sensiblement développer elle représente
environ 5 points elle représentait part
d'environ 5% en 2007
en 2008 l approcher les 10% et même 13,4
pour cent en juillet dernier la loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui précise donc
les modalités d'ouverture à la
concurrence des services ferroviaires
internationaux de voyageurs à compter du
13 décembre prochain et des transports
collectifs urbains en ile-de-france à
contrer du 3 décembre prochain et
permettez-moi bien évidemment de
m'arrêter quelques instants sur ce
dernier point que les circonstances
n'ont pas permis d'examiner ici au sénat
et je souhaite devant vous clarifier la
portée exacte de cet article il a pour
objet de préparer l'ouverture à la
concurrence des transports urbains en
région ile-de-france ouverture imposé
par la réglementation européenne
à compter du 3 décembre 2009 c'est à
dire dans un
il ne concerne ni le réseau rff ni la
sncf il se borne à transcrire à l'île de
france
une situation qui je vous le rappelle
existe dans toutes les agglomérations
françaises
le choix du gouvernement est une
ouverture équilibré dans l'intérêt des
usagers
une mise en concurrence pour les
nouvelles service institué à compter du
3 décembre 2009 et une ouverture
progressive sur les traire services
existants les bus dans 15 ans les
tramways dans 20 ans et les métros dans
30 ans l'idée est évidemment et de ne
pas désorganiser les services en place
de la ratp
par ailleurs le gouvernement confie à la
ratp la responsabilité de la gestion de
l'infrastructure
c'est une évidence que la ratp doit
avoir cette gestion pour des raisons de
cohérence et pour des raisons de
sécurité parce que nous croyons nous au
service public de transport en région
ile de france
je voudrais vous rappeler que cet
article ne spoliant à rien le stif de
ses actifs il assure une répartition des
biens qui donne au stif les moyens
concrets de mettre en concurrence des
futurs exploitants et à la ratp les
moyens de jouer pleinement son rôle de
gestionnaire des infrastructures le 6 le
stif pardon devient propriétaire du
matériel roulant
actuellement propriétés de la ratp et la
ratp devient propriétaire de toute
l'infrastructure
sachant qu'aujourd'hui elle en est déjà
propriétaire de la moitié
cet échange de biens qui se fit dans les
deux sens est un échange équilibré et
cet article donne au stif la capacité de
confier l'exploitation des nouvelles
lignes et à terme des lignes existence
après une mise en concurrence et de
jouer ainsi pleinement son rôle
d'autorité organisatrice de transport
certains auraient aimé aller plus loin
en ouvrant à la concurrence les
transports ferroviaires régionaux de
voyageurs
dominique bussereau
a dit à plusieurs reprises qu'il y était
favorable le comité des parties
prenantes présidée par le sénateur
grignon doit en préciser les modalités
pratiques concernant les personnels les
matériels roulants et les services en
gare modalités qui présideront à une
future expérimentation nous devons
veiller à ce que la concurrence dans les
transports s'effectue dans les
conditions équilibrées loyal et
parfaitement transparente grâce à des
dispositifs de régulation efficace et je
voudrais a insisté notamment sur deux
points
revenir sur le secteur ferroviaire pour
vous indiquer que les deux mesures
phares de ce texte sont bien entendu la
création de l'autorité indépendante de
régulation ferroviaire et la création au
sein la sncf d'une direction de
l'exploitation ce service spécialisé
séparée du reste de l'entreprise aura
pour mission de gérer le trafic et la
circulation sur le réseau ferroviaire
national
le parlement a également insisté sur la
neutralité de la gestion des gares pour
une bonne confiance
la création d'une direction des gares au
sein de la sncf va dans ce sens vous
avez également souhaité un rapport du
gouvernement sur un éventuel transfert
des gares sncf affrète des gares fret
pardon à rff bien entendu le
gouvernement mènera les travaux
nécessaires à la remise de ce rapport il
ne juge toutefois pas opportun de
décider un tel transfert au moment où
avec l'ensemble des opérateurs au
premier rang desquels fret sncf
il engage un plan un grand plan de
redynamisation du fret enfin dans le
transport routier de marchandises
l'encadrement du cabotage permettra la
profession d'envisager la concurrence
européenne avec plus de sérénité
la loi prévoit également des
dispositions permettant de mieux
contrôler le respect de la
réglementation de ce secteur
je tiens enfin à souligner pour conclure
que les libérations l'élaboration de ce
texte à dos des lieux
une concertation particulièrement riche
et frac et fructueuse je voudrais à
nouveau saluer le travail réalisé par
votre rapporteur qui a su je crois être
à l'écouté de tous les acteurs pour
aboutir à une solution équilibrée et
consensuelle je vous remercie pour votre
attention
la parole est à madame mireille cherche
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues près d'une
année après l'examen par notre haute
assemblée de ce texte déclaré en urgence
nous voici réunis pour l'adopter dans sa
forme définitive tel qu'issu des travaux
des travaux de la commission mixte
paritaire
l'urgence dans ce cas visait donc plus à
priver les assemblées d'une seconde
lecture qu'à accélérer le processus
législatif qui a été bien longue
nous déplorons ces nouvelles pratiques
qui prive les parlementaires de leurs
prérogatives
de plus une seconde lecture aurait été
utile au regard des nombreuses
évolutions du texte et notamment
l'introduction d'un titre entier par
rapport au projet de loi initial
pourtant sur le fond la philosophie de
ce texte reste bien la même il s'agit
d'ouvrir à la concurrence et transports
ferrés internationaux de voyageurs et
maintenant routier grâce à
l'intervention massive du gouvernement
par voie d'amendements sur ce texte
pourtant nous continuons de penser
qu'avant toute nouvelle déréglementation
un bilan des libéralisations réduit est
réalisé afin d'étudier les conséquences
concrètes en termes environnemental en
termes d'emplois et de services publics
des politiques européennes affirmant la
concurrence libre et non faussée comme
l'alpha et l'oméga de toute politique
publique en effet de manière mécanique
depuis maintenant des décennies les
institutions européennes auxquelles vous
participez s'acharne à prôner le
démantèlement des services publics
nationaux au nom de la modernité et de
l'efficacité
c'est vrai pour le fret c'est vrai pour
le rail ça sera vrai tout à l'heure pour
la poste mais que constate-t-on
l'ouverture à la concurrence a permis
qu'une seule chose que des opérateurs
privés puissent faire des bénéfices dans
des secteurs auparavant réservés
à l'intervention de la seule puissance
publique pour les usagers c'est la
double peine les tarifs augmentent et
les services rendus se détériore objet
de la première directive de
libéralisation le fret ferroviaire n'a
cessé de décliner depuis l'ouverture à
la concurrence à la politique de volume
impulsée par le ministre gayssot vous
avez substitué une politique de
rentabilité économique favorisant les
autoroutes ferroviaires et abandonnant
le wagon isolé
pourtant ces autoroutes n'ont de sens
que si l'on renforce parallèlement le
wagon isolé
cette nouvelle politique de
compétitivité au sein même du fret a
laissé des territoires entiers et de
nombreuses pme sans solution et moi qui
suis une élue représentants dans le
massif central je vous assure que de
nombreuses pme sont sans solution
l'activité de fret a été filialisée
empêchant tout péréquation au sein de la
sncf entre les activités rentables et
les activités non rentables et les
effets d'annoncé récente de votre
gouvernement et de la direction de la
sncf sont tronqués puisque le projet
fret d'avenir
au lieu de permettre un essor du fret
entérine l'abandon pur et simple du
wagon isolé c'est décisions se font
toujours au mépris des impératifs
d'aménagement du territoire du
développement économique du
développement des pme dans ces
territoires
ainsi malgré les déclarations
d'intention lors du grenelle de
l'environnement
les actes posés par ce projet de loi et
par votre gouvernement reste
profondément anti écologique
si un conseil de développement durable
du réseau ferré national qui ne
comprendra aucun parlementaire je le
souligne est créée par cette loi
vous refusez toujours de reconnaître que
l'activité de wagon
isolé relève de l'intérêt général
sacrifier cette activité s'est pourtant
m sur les routes des millions de camions
supplémentaires
cette idée que tout ce qui n'est pas
rentable doit être abandonnée n'est ni
moderne ni écologique comme vous voulez
nous faire croire
c'est impératif de rentabilité
économique est inopérant si l'on se
situe du côté de l'intérêt général et la
satisfaction des besoins du plus grand
nombre
être le garant de l'intérêt général et
la responsabilité première de l'état et
non comme j'ai pu l'entendre dans les
débats de l'assemblée nationale de
veiller à la concurrence sans
discrimination le marché on le sait ne
se laisse pas régulé à ce titre nous
déplorons que ce texte par le biais des
opérateurs de proximité remettent en
cause l'unicité du réseau national et
justifient que rff se débarrase une
partie de son réseau jugés non rentables
à l'article 2 tout en envisageant de lui
confier la responsabilité des gares de
fret à l'article 2 bis la modernité ce
n'est donc pas de laisser la main
invisible du marché ou plutôt la raf
réglementer l'activité des transports
être moderne c'est investir pour
moderniser les transports publics et les
infrastructures afin d'améliorer leur
efficacité et leur fiabilité
c'est également mailler le territoire en
s'appuyant sur le réseau existant et le
fortifier la région ile de france par le
biais du stif a contribué à développer
l'offre de transport sur cette région
par des investissements massifs
cela vous est insupportable et vous
faites le choix
au détour d'un amendement plus que
contestable tant sur la forme que sur le
fond de transférer purement et
simplement son patrimoine à la ratp
au-delà de votre volonté inébranlable de
remettre la main
sur les transports en ile-de-france voir
sur le conseil régional nous l'avons
bien compris cet amendement pose un
problème de fond vous martelez sans cesc
bruxelles interdit les aides d'état vous
prenez même cela comme justification
pour ouvrir le capital de la poste
mais parallèlement et de façon très
surprenante vous offrait gratuitement
l'air et épais un patrimoine gigantesque
de plusieurs milliards
c'est un double discours difficile à
entendre ce fameux amendement établit
également un calendrier fixant à la
concurrence pour les métros à 2039 soit
dans 30 ans ne traduit donc cet
amendement sinon votre volonté à vouloir
faire dire aux règlements au sp ce que
nous ce qu'il ne dit pas en effet ce
règlement n'impose pas l'ouverture à la
concurrence des transports régionaux et
urbains
il encadre simplement les formes
choisies par les autorités
organisatrices
comment ne pas faire le lien avec ce que
proposait pour les ter notre collègue
sénateur enel en première lecture au
sénat où la proposition du député
mariton qui proposait de définir un
échéancier pour ouvrir à la concurrence
les ter et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le ministre monsieur le secrétaire
d'état y est en effet favorable
je vous rappelle donc une nouvelle fois
la réponse de nathalie kosciusko morizet
lors d'une séance de questions elle
affirmait je cite que l'objet du
règlement au s p n'est pas d'anticiper
l'ouverture à la concurrence des
services ferroviaires intérieur vous
n'avez à la bouche que les mots
concurrence libre et non faussée
et ce alors même que tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge indiquant que
ce modèle économique libéral est en
total échec les conséquences sociales du
règne du marché que subissent
aujourd'hui de plein fouet nos
concitoyens méritent une prise de
conscience urgente sur vos erreurs et
non d'accélérer l'ampleur de vos
réformes dans votre logique
vous près la raf nouveau gendarme
ferroviaire pour accompagner cette
ouverture à la concurrence les pouvoirs
qui lui sont confiées sont importants
afin de garantir l'arrivée des nouveaux
entrants dans des conditions favorables
ces autorités de régulation dite
indépendante sur le nouveau modèle de la
puissance publique afin de garantir
transparence et indépendance
mais la transparence monsieur le
ministre vous ne l'obtiendrez pas par un
désengagement de l'état de ses
responsabilités mais bien au contraire
en garantissant des espaces de
démocratie mais de cela vous êtes très
loin suppression massive dé lui par la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
muselage du parlement par les nouveaux
règlements des assemblées suppression
autoritaire de la taxe professionnelle
etc la liste est longue
cette autorité disposera donc d'un
pouvoir réglementaire et d'un pouvoir de
sanction s'agissant du pouvoir
réglementaire il s'agit d'un pouvoir par
délégation mais dans le silence du
ministre c'est thomas legg homologation
est réputée acquise ce qui correspond à
une grave atteinte au principe de
constitutionnalité du pouvoir
réglementaire
sur le fond nous trouvons que la
concentration de ses pouvoirs dans les
mains de personnalités qui ne seront pas
comptables de leurs actes est absolument
scandaleuse
d'autre part nous re 9 ne renouvelons
notre opposition à la supériorité de la
raf sur l'établissement de sécurité
réaffirmé par l'article 9 de cette loi
qui indique que le respect des règles de
sécurité ne saurait avoir pour effet
d'entraver le bon fonctionnement du
marché concurrentiel oui je termine
nous continuons de penser que la
sécurité ne doit pas être sacrifiée sur
l'autel de la rentabilité économique
les débats ont aussi permis d'intégrer
dans ce texte la création sein de la
sncf
regroupant les quatorze mille agents
travaillant pour le compte de refesse et
d'autre part le fait que la gestion des
gares
vrai aujourd'hui faire l'objet d'un
traitement spécifique par la sncf dans
ses comptes
et ce alors qu aucune direction
communautaire ne l'imposent ce zèle du
gouvernement français est encore plus
inexplicable alors même que chacun
s'accorde à penser que l'existence des
services publics dans notre pays a
permis d'amortir la crise économique que
nous traversons
pourtant votre logique reste toujours la
même cela donne dans ce secteur pourtant
si stratégique que celui des transports
le schéma suivi suivant pardon s'appuie
sur les collectivités pour financer sur
leur territoire les services non
rentables sous peine de les supprimer et
parallèlement nous ouvre à la
concurrence des axes rentable on
développe les partenariats privé public
et on permet au géant de l'immobilier de
réaliser des profits colossaux
l'état lui se désengager notamment dans
la loi de finances et l'aide au
transport combiné ne cesse de décroître
de 35 millions cette année contre 90 en
2002 les subventions à la filt sont en
baisse de 220 millions la révolution
verte prônée par monsieur borloo dans
cette assemblée
en introduction des débats sur le
grenelle 2 ne verra donc pas le jour en
2010 à ce titre la reprise de la dette
de rff n'est toujours pas à l'ordre du
jour même si je me félicite que ce texte
prévoit que le gouvernement remette un
rapport au parlement sur cette question
avant fin 2009
il est donc urgent de le faire vous
l'aurez au final bien compris mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
les sénatrices et les sénateurs du
groupe crc spg ne pourront voter ce
texte qui par une logique récurrentes
démantèle le service public ferroviaire
je vous remercie
allez la parole est à notre collègue
monsieur michel teston
mais j'aime pas ça
aujourd'hui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
chères et chers collègues depuis le
début de la décennie 1990 pour tenter
d'enrayer le déclin du mode de transport
ferroviaire par rapport aux modes de
transport routier l'union européenne a
adopté un texte de base la directive 91
440 est successivement plus géant
directive constituante trois paquets
ferroviaires relatifs respectivement aux
infrastructures et à l'ouverture à la
concurrence du fret d'abord du transport
international de voyageurs
ensuite la transcription en droit
français d'une partie de ses directives
et déjà intervenue ainsi pour la
séparation de la gestion de
l'infrastructure ferroviaire et de celle
de l'exploitation des services de
transport la france
ancré à rff est même allé plus loin que
la seule séparation comptable exigé par
l'union européenne
un établissement public de sécurité
ferroviaire a été mis en place
des spécifications techniques communes
ont été mises en oeuvre en matière de
signalisation et pour la construction de
matériels moteur pouvant capter
plusieurs types de courant électrique
enfin le monopole de la sncf sur le
service intérieur de marchandises a été
supprimée au 1er janvier 2006 il reste
ce jour à transcrire une série de
dispositions du troisième paquet
ferroviaire ainsi qu'une partie
d'une directive relevant du premier
paquet quel est l'objet de ce projet a
c'est de ce côté oui mais ils ne se sont
pas trompés tel est l'objet de ce projet
de loi qui prévoit d'abord l'ouverture à
la concurrence des services
internationaux de transport de voyageurs
à compter du 13 octobre 2009 ainsi que
la possibilité sous certaines conditions
de prendre et de déposer des voyageurs
dans les gares françaises situées sur le
trajet d'un service internations par
contre le texte ne prévoit pas
l'ouverture à la concurrence des
services régionaux de transport de
voyageurs aucune directive européenne ne
l'imposé aux états membres ni d'ailleurs
me semble-t-il le règlement relatif aux
services publics de transport de
voyageurs par chemin de fer et par route
appelée règlement au sp il vise aussi à
créer les conditions de développement
des opérateurs ferroviaires de proximité
ce qui se traduit notamment par la fin
du monopole de la sncf pour l'entretien
des lignes à faible trafic réservée au
transport de marchandises
il prévoit en outre la création d'une
autorité administrative indépendante
chargée de la régulation c'est à dire de
garantir un accès équitable et non
discriminatoire des opérateurs au réseau
les deux derniers titres du projet de
loi contient des dispositions relatives
à des concessions routières et aux
conditions de travail des personnels
navigants de l'aviation civile
je rappelle mes chers collègues que le 9
mars dernier le groupe socialiste a voté
contre ce
texte en effet si quelques-uns
quelques-uns seulement de nos
amendements ont été adoptés à savoir la
certification des conducteurs de train
la réintégration dans la loterie de
l'expression service public de transport
ferroviaire ou encore l'affirmation du
rôle de rff comme gestionnaire du réseau
ferré national
il n'y a pas de réelles avancées sur la
question essentielle des relations entre
rff et la sncf
pourtant alors que l'endettement de rff
est identifiée comme la principale
difficulté en matière d'investissements
ferroviaires
le projet de loi ne propose aucune
solution afin de rendre possible le
remboursement progressif de la dette de
rff
il convient pourtant de clarifier les
relations rff et la sncf
dès lors pourquoi ne pas avoir profité
de ce texte pour le faire et revenir sur
ce que beaucoup considèrent comme le
raté de la loi de 1990 est en effet
principalement préoccupés par la
question de la dette ferroviaire qui
risquait de léser la france dans la
perspective du respect des critères de
maastricht législateur français avait
alors négliger l'élémentaire logique il
y en a résulté une véritable usine à gaz
on en reparlera lors du prochain débat
dans la mesure où rff se trouvent
contraints par la loi de délégués
l'essentiel de ses missions à la sncf
qui est par ailleurs en opérateur
ferroviaire théoriquement à égalité avec
les autres dans les faits l'indépendance
est certes
pardonnez moi l'expression bruxelles au
compatibles mais elle n'est pas réel
puisque des relations commerciales
contraintes lie les deux entités
relations commerciales qui interpelle
dans son rapport sur l'organisation
ferroviaire notre collègue hubert haenel
par le même voeu le site d'un constat de
carence de l'état en matière de
gouvernance et de financement du système
ferroviaire
fin de citation d'autres rapports
apportent leur pierre au diagnostic
d'extraordinaire complexité du système
français est parfois des pistes de
solution le rapport de la cour des
comptes d'avril 2008 intitulé je cite le
réseau ferroviaire
une réforme inachevée une stratégie
incertaine fin de citation et le rapport
d'information numéro 1 875 d'hervé
mariton publié en mai 2008 intitulé je
cite les péages ferroviaires pour quoi
faire
fin de citation s'accordent sur les
mêmes constats l'urgence est à
l'adoption de dispositions de
simplification et au remboursement de la
dette de rff
à l'instar de ce qui a été fait en
allemagne en autriche et en italie
la meilleure solution consisterait à
notre sens en la mise en place d'une
organisation où le gestionnaire du
réseau serait une filiale de la sncf
cette organisation qui paraît bien
fonctionné dans les états précités
suppose cependant que l'état reprenne la
dette de rff
près de 28 milliards d'euros aujourd'hui
faute de quoi celle-ci apparaît dans les
comptes consolidés de l'ensemble avec de
lourdes conséquences
temps bien sûr pour rff que pour la sncf
et ce dans un contexte caractérisé par
la confiance par la concurrence
ceci m'amène à la principale critique
d'autres groupes à l'égard de ce texte
nous considérons monsieur le ministre
que ce projet comme la directive qu'il a
pour objet de transposer est inspiré par
l'idée qu'il n'ya pas de salut pour les
services internationaux de transport de
voyageurs en dehors de la concurrence
comme si la qualité du service ou encore
la productivité étaient systématiquement
liés à l'ouverture à la concurrence mais
qui peut le croire or force est de
constater que les arguments sont rares
pour justifier l'ouverture à la
concurrence des services de transport de
voyageurs
pourtant cette marche forcée amorcée au
début des années 1990 n'a jamais été
remise en question et ce malgré les
expériences peu concluantes de quelques
pionniers en la matière je pense en
particulier à la grande-bretagne cas
d'ailleurs depuis fait un peu machine
arrière
en outre comme l'illustrent les
nouvelles lignes directrices
communautaires sur les aides d'état aux
entreprises ferroviaires du 22 juillet
cette libéralisation s'accompagne de
temps de dérogations et entrantes horse
au principe de libre concurrence
inhérentes pour besoins du secteur
allant du financement des
infrastructures ferroviaires à l'aide à
l'achat et au renouvellement du matériel
roulant en passant par l'annulation de
dettes
la restructuration de branche fret ou
encore les aides pour la correction
d'externalités négatives que sa
justification originelle est devenu
difficile à défendre à l'avenir avec le
dispositif qui nous est proposé on
pourrait bien assister à un écrémage gay
ligne considéré comme rentable avec une
forte concurrence sur ces quelques
linéaire ou si les prix baissent la
qualité des services baisse sera
probablement aussi
quant à l'emploi
il ne pourra qu'en pâtir les opérateurs
historiques risque bien d'être en
difficulté alors même qu'ils devront
continuer à assurer le transport
international de voyageurs sur les
autres lignes
c'est à dire celles peu ou pas rentables
l'ouverture à la concurrence n'est donc
pas la solution à retenir pour
développer les services internationaux
de voyage les membres de notre groupe
considère qu'il existe une autre voie
écarté par l'union européenne sur
l'autel du libéralisme
cette voie était et demeure l'incitation
à la coopération entre les grands
opérateurs ferroviaires
ces derniers l'ont d'ailleurs bien
compris ce qui explique leur
rapprochement en vue d'offrir des
services qui dans l'ensemble fonctionne
bien
ses services tout le monde les connaît
il suffit donc de les rappeler
eurostar thalys lyria alleo artesia et
elipsos partenariat de la sncf avec tous
les autres grands réseaux européens
installés dans les états qui sont situés
autour de notre nation
alors j'en viens à l'apport si on peut
dire de l'assemblée nationale à ce texte
l'assemblée nationale a adopté un
certain nombre de nos modifications au
projet de loi adopté par dans un certain
nombre de modifications pas de nos
modifications au projet de loi qui sont
bien loin de répondre à notre attente
à l'exception toutefois de la nouvelle
rédaction de l'article 3 qui prévoit
qu'avant la fin de l'année 2009 le
gouvernement doit remettre au parlement
un rapport présentant les solutions
proposées pour le remboursement de la
dette de rff nous avions ici même
déposer un tel amendement et à la
demande du rapporteur et du ministre
nous avons accepté que notre amendement
passe mais il a été largement édulcoré
par les propositions de la commission et
du ministre et donc nous considérons que
l'assemblée nationale a été en la
matière plus audacieuse que la majorité
sénatoriale et qui n'a pas suivi
totalement notre abonnement
mais la principale modification voté à
l'assemblée nationale est lié à
l'adoption nuitamment le 22 septembre
d'un amendement gouvernemental qui
transfère les actifs du stif à la ratp
ou du moins une partie de ses actifs et
qui place celle ci dans une situation
délicate
quand vous en ayez dit monsieur le
ministre par rapport au règlement aux
aspects relatifs aux services publics de
transport de voyageurs par chemin de fer
est patent cet amendement a en outre été
adoptée en totale violation des droits
du parlement puisque introduit devant
l'assemblée nationale alors que la
lecture au sénat avait déjà eu lieu et
que la déclaration d'urgence privé celui
ci de toute possibilité d'examiner
cette disposition à voir la commission
mixte paritaire
il ya d'ailleurs et nous le verrons lors
du vote sur les articles
tout à l'heure qu'il ya toute une série
d'articles ont été rajoutés sur lesquels
le sénat n'a pas eu à se prononcer lors
de la commission mixte paritaire du 27
octobre
les parlementaires socialistes src ont
défendu des amendements pour la
suppression de la disposition relative
au stif à la ratp amendement qui
proposait en particulier de procéder à
un recensement des biens et des actifs
de manière transparente et paritaire de
manière à pouvoir formuler les
propositions les plus adaptées au regard
de l'efficacité du réseau et de
l'équilibré budgétaire des différentes
entités concernées
j'aurais tendance à dire peine perdue
nous avons essayé les parlementaires de
gauche qui étaient présents député
sénatrices et sénateurs d'obtenir
satisfaction
ces amendements ont été rejetés
systématiquement alors au terme de
l'examen de ce texte par le parlement
examens qui ne me satisfait pas puisque
c'est un texte qui a été examiné en
procédure accélérée
nous faisons le constat que ce projet de
loi ouvrant à la concurrence les
services internationaux de transport de
voyageurs en application d'une directive
européenne certains ceci nous empêche
pas d'être d'un avis opposé
parce que comme je l'expliquais lors de
l'examen du texte ici
lors des explications de vote le 9 mars
dernier parce que nous sommes convaincus
que le développement du transport
ferroviaire de voyageurs passent par la
coopération entre les grands opérateurs
historiques et pas du tout par une
concurrence sauvage entre par ailleurs
ce texte n'apporte aucune vraie réponse
à la question pourtant essentielle de la
résorption de la dette de rff
enfin nous n'acceptons pas la manière
dont le sénat a été privé du fait de la
déclaration d'urgence de la possibilité
d'examiner l'amendement gouvernemental
introduit à l'assemblée nationale après
lecture au sénat
je fais référence et bien sûr à cet
amendement relatif à la haye la ratp au
stif et par ailleurs nous sommes vous
l'avez compris totalement opposé à son
contenu
alors je ne vous surprendrai pas en vous
disant que nous ne voterons pas ce
projet de loi que nous voterons contre
ce projet de loi
nous pensons au delà même de ce projet
lui même qu'il dépend d'un choix qui a
été fait au niveau de l'union européenne
un choix qui est celui de séparer les
infrastructures de l'exploitation avec
toutes les conséquences que cela
comporte
je fais simplement remarquer que les
chemins de fer japonais qui ont
certainement le meilleur réseau de
trains de voyageurs au monde n'ont pas
fait ce choix que les américains en
matière de fret qui ont un bon réseau
n'ont pas fait ce choix
j'ai véritablement l'impression que
depuis un certain nombre d'années
bon nombre de décideurs européens se
sentent trompés
mais malgré tout puisque nous sommes
socialistes nous restons optimistes
optimiste qu un jour l'union européenne
sera capable de faire des choix qui
permettent de développer réellement le
chemin de fer en europe
c'est aussi logique par rapport à ce que
font tous les états ne sont pas les
seuls nous attend gage et dans le
grenelle de l'environnement dans le
grenelle de l'environnement et donc nous
restons optimistes pour l'avenir
un jour nous en sommes certains on
pourra bâtir un système ferroviaire
intégrés qui reposera sur la coopération
entre les jours et qui répondra
réellement à la tente des européens
la parole est à monsieur yvon collin
choïgou mais monsieur le président on ce
ministre mes chers collègues nous voici
parvenus au terme de l'examen d'un
projet de loi qui en dépit des
apparences de technicité parfois
trompeuses recèle finalement de
véritables enjeux pour l'avenir immédiat
de nos principaux modes de transport
ce texte pourrait devait permettre de
mieux mettre en valeur notre mode de
transport ferroviaire outil fondamental
du développement économique et du
désenclavement de notre territoire et à
plus forte raison des territoires ruraux
la question des transports est vaste car
l attrait non seulement à la mobilité
mais aussi à l'accessibilité à la
fracture territoriale et aux enjeux
environnementaux
le secteur des transports mobilise des
moyens colossaux et les efforts en sa
faveur devront être amplifiées même dans
un cadre libéralisé en effet cette
libéralisation est sans doute eux elle
est redoutée et ce n'est pas que pour
des raisons idéologiques
on peut en effet souhaité la concurrence
lorsque celle ci contribue à diversifier
l'offre et à faire baisser les tarifs
pour les usagers
mais ne nous leurrons pas aucun
partenaire privé ne s'occupera des
lignes peu rentables qui ont pour seule
vocation qui ont pour seule vocation de
répondre souci légitime d'aménagement du
territoire mais et nous savons bien que
l'état les collectivités locales seront
toujours toujours sollicité dans leur
rôle régulateur
c'est la raison pour laquelle en vérité
notre pays à transposer les directives
européennes à demi mot
le projet souffrent d'autre part de
manque d'ambition avec le schéma global
de transport
l'absence d'évaluation et d'étude
d'impact nous disposions pourtant de
trois ans de recul pour examiner les
effets de la transposition d'une
directive les préconisations du grenelle
de l'environnement aurait dû amener la
cmp a plus de volontarisme dans le
domaine des transports propres
ce texte nous donne donc monsieur le
ministre peu de satisfaction par rapport
aux espoirs et par rapport aux attentes
qu'il aurait dû susciter
or on nous a affirmé que la
libéralisation et l'ouverture à la
concurrence augmenterait le transfert le
transport le transport modal de la route
vers le rail
or rien ne permet de soutenir cette
information en l'état actuel une
entreprise qui se situe sur le plan
géographique à l'écart des grandes
lignes aura nécessairement recours à des
moyens de faibles livraison au mode de
transport le plus fiable et le moins
cher ce qui n'est pas le cas du service
de transport par wagons isolés devenu
extrêmement coûteux mais aussi très
aléatoire je regrette également que le
texte ne prennent pas réellement en
compte le principe de compensation des
communes traversées par les lignes à
grande vitesse comme nous le souhaitions
ici tous il aurait été très
significatifs de donner un signal
important en matière d'aménagement du
territoire
ce sont principalement les petites
communes qui auraient été concernés par
cette motivation
comment dans un cadre totalement
concurrentiel la survie des lignes
dédiées aux principes d'aménagement du
territoire monsieur le ministre sera
telle garantie
le texte issu des travaux de la cmp ne
répond pas à l'évidence à cette
interrogation
beaucoup de questions d'autre part à j-2
les élus car la mobilisation des usagers
contre les fermetures de glace de cas de
gale n'est pas mince comme bats pour
beaucoup c'est le combat d'une vie
la gare demeurant un symbole de la
racine mandé sommes sur un territoire
nous devions rechercher l'excellence
pour nos territoires
celle-ci passé par le désenclavement et
l'accessibilité sans lesquels il n'y a
pas d'activités touristiques ou
économiques possibles
aujourd'hui nous restons monsieur le
ministre sur notre faim certes le
développement des lignes à grande
vitesse est vital nous savons bien les
lignes secondaires demeurent
malheureusement les grandes oubliées de
la politique gouvernementale et nous le
regrettons
à l'instar de mes collègues du groupe
socialiste et communiste il ne me
semblait pas du tout mais alors pas du
tout aux porteurs de faire passer en
catimini à l'assemblée nationale un
amendement gouvernemental tendant à
modifier profondément l'organisation des
transports publics d'île de france sans
même que le sénat puisse l'examiner sans
concertation préalable sans même que
notre assemblée ne se prononce du fait
de la détestable procédure accélérée
un nouveau règlement devrait entrer en
vigueur dès le 3 décembre prochain
le capital du stif serait transférée à
la ratp
sans demander l'avis des syndicats ni de
la région ni de la ville de paris ni les
départements bonjour la concertation les
modalités d'adoption de cet amendement
on fait l'effet d'une bombe devant les
élus de droite comme de gauche
sans même parler du fond c'est la
méthode elle même qui est condamnable et
d'ailleurs je remercie notre rapporteur
francis grignon de l'avoir lui-même
rappelé
néanmoins le principal apport du projet
de loi et la création d'une autorité
administrative indépendante de
régulation des activités ferroviaires
la notion d'encadrement et de régulation
prend en effet tout son sens aujourd'hui
cette autorité veillera à garantir le
libre accès au réseau
c'est un élément positif qui convient
sans doute de souligner
l'autorité de régulation des activités
ferroviaires pourra non seulement
instruire les plantes des différents
acteurs du secteur
mais aussi prendre l'initiative d'
enquête ou d'investigation dotée d'un
pouvoir de sanction
elles pointent également infliger une
amende pouvant représenter jusqu'à 100 %
du chiffre d'affaires de l'opérateur
enfin mes amis mes chers collègues je
conclurai mon propos par quelques
observations relatives aux dispositions
touchant à l'aviation civile un secteur
qu'elle je suis particulièrement
sensible de par ma fonction de
rapporteur au sénat du budget de
l'aviation civile en première lecture
j'avais déposé un amendement visant à
définir la notion de mission d'en
préciser le contenu est également de
s'assurer dans le respect des mesures
prises pour assurer la sécurité du vol
des du respect des droits des passagers
afin que ces derniers puissent être
rapatriés en cas de nécessité
et ce dans les meilleurs délais le texte
hacmp propose une solution alternative à
ma proposition sans définir la mission
il dispose que dans le respect des
mesures prises pour assurer la sécurité
des vols
le personnel navigant est tenu sauf cas
de force majeure ou d'impossibilité
médical d'assurer son service programmée
entre deux passages à l'une des bases
d'affectation il s'agit là donc
compromis raisonnables auxquelles
finalement je peux me rallie néanmoins
mes chers collègues en dépit des
quelques avancées techniques du texte
mais un sens très insatisfaisante
parlement que cruelle des mesures liées
à l'aménagement du territoire et au
désenclavement de notre pays
la grande majorité des membres de mon
groupe ne peut approuver ce projet à
l'issue de la cndh et aussi pour les
motifs que je viens de développer tout
particulièrement à raison des
dispositions sur le stif disposition
dont nous ne partageons ni le fonds ni
la forme dont elles ont été introduites
dans le texte
eh bien ceux d'entre nous qui s'était
abstenue lors du passage de ce texte
devant le sénat
votre homme cette fois ci contre les
conclusions de la scène
je vous remercie de votre attention la
parole est à monsieur michel bécot
michel président
what c'est plus facile
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous allons
voter un texte dont nous n'avons rien à
craindre je dirai tout à gagner dans le
droit fil du grenelle de l'environnement
ils organisent une concurrence régulée
dans le but de développer les transports
ferroviaires il développe les transports
en commun il renforce la puissance du
transport maritime
issu de la transposition d'une directive
européenne visant à réguler la
concurrence
ce texte est devenu grâce notamment aux
travaux du sénat un texte fondateur en
matière de transport ce projet de loi
comprend des dispositions ayant trait au
transport ferroviaire est guidé au
transport routier au transport aérien et
au transport maritime
il s'inscrit dans une période de
mutation importante des transports en
france comme en europe
je veux souligner à cet égard que ce
texte intervient dans un contexte
particulièrement favorable au fret
ferroviaire puisque le président de la
république a souhaité engager un
programme sans précédent de 7 milliards
d'euros en vue de la création d'un
réseau d'autoroutes ferroviaires est
d'un réseau de fret à grande vitesse
le fil conducteur de la future loi est
claire
l'ouverture à la concurrence du secteur
des transports et à sa nécessaire
régulation
au terme des paquets ferroviaires
européens successifs les infrastructures
ferrer sont entrés dans le champ
concurrentiel en 2001 le transport
ferroviaire de fret est ouvert à la
concurrence depuis le 1er avril 2005
2006 pardon et les services de transport
international de voyageurs doivent
l'être au plus tard au 1er janvier 2010
à ce statut luminis nous devons insister
sur un point qui m'apparaît absolument
majeur il ne faut pas se dissimuler
derrière l'union européenne aux motifs
que celle ci nous impose une concurrence
que nous serions contraints de subir la
concurrence n'est pas une chose nocives
ou honteuses venu de bruxelles pour
dégrader nos modes de transport elles
propres elle présente des avantages
indéniables pour
le développement des transports au
profit des clients et de tous les
voyageurs
cela est vrai pour les transports
aériens mais également pour le transport
ferroviaire de fret
songeons aux perspectives que le fret
ferroviaire ouvre à notre pays il n'y a
aucune raison de douter que l'ouverture
à la concurrence permettra de développer
le transport international des voyageurs
en suscitant la création de nouveaux
services de nouvelles activités et de
nouveaux emplois
de la même façon nous sommes favorables
à l'ouverture à la concurrence sur
transports ferroviaires régionaux de
voyageurs qui a très bien fonctionné en
allemagne les modalités doivent
évidemment en être précisés nous attend
on en voit beaucoup d'intérêt le rapport
de notre collègue francis réunion sur ce
sujet qui devrait permettre de proposer
des solutions aux vrais problèmes posés
je pense au devenir des personnels ou à
la propriété des matériels roulants
la france entend respecter ses
engagements et obligations
communautaires et ce projet vise à
transposer l'ensemble des textes
applicables au secteur ferroviaire
ce mouvement de libéralisation constitue
une chance à l'échelle européenne tant
pour la sncf que pour l'ensemble des
entreprises françaises en ce qui
concerne l'ouverture à la concurrence
dans les transports guidés
nous soutenons les adaptations
nécessaires pour mettre l'organisation
des transports franciliens en conformité
avec le règlement européen relatif aux
services publics de conspirent de
voyageurs par le chemin de fer et par la
route notamment la redéfinition des
relations entre le stif et la ratp
si nous ne rejetons pas l'ouverture à la
concurrence du transport ferroviaire
nous souhaitons en revanche qu'elle
s'effectue dans des conditions
équilibrées et parfaitement transparent
l'ouverture impose l'institution d'un
dispositif de régulation efficace à même
de garantir l'accès libre et non
discriminatoire au réseau ferré national
de tous les opérateurs
qu'il s'agisse d'entreprises ferroviaire
historique ou des pme ferroviaires qui
sont des opérateurs ferroviaires de
proximité
le texte crée donc une autorité
administrative indépendante autorité de
régulation des activités ferroviaires
véritable clé de voûte d'une nouvelle
gouvernance de ce secteur
je souhaite l'encore insisté sur le fait
que cette autorité qui jouera un rôle de
première importance dans le
fonctionnement de notre système
ferroviaire n'exonère en rien l'état de
ses responsabilités
je pense à celle fondamentale qui
consiste à veiller à ce que
l'organisation du système ferroviaire
favorise une concurrence sans
discrimination à cet égard la gestion d
sign on et la gestion des gares sont
deux éléments clés en la matière sur
lesquels un équilibre satisfaisant a été
trouvé et nous nous en félicitons
ainsi la réforme participera à la
nécessaire restructuration de l'activité
de fret de la sncf réforme primordial
tant pour l'entreprise que pour la tenue
des engagements du grenelle de
l'environnement l'une des priorités du
grenelle est en effet le report vers des
modes de transport peu polluants et plus
respectueux de l'environnement
l'ouverture à la concurrence du
transport ferroviaire est aujourd'hui
une réalité le paysage ferroviaire est
en train de se modifier en profondeur
son développement doit répondre à des
nouveaux enjeux
il s'ouvre à la concurrence et à
l'arrivée de nouveaux entrants
il a un site à faire évoluer
l'organisation de notre système de
transport
ce projet de loi répond à des défis tout
en s'inscrivant complètement dans les
objectifs du grenelle de l'environnement
ce texte permettra de développer des
activités ferroviaires au plan national
et international
notre expérience en matière ferroviaire
se verra confortée et bénéficiera au
secteur tout entier
j'ai surtout évoqué les dispositions
relatives au transport ferroviaire
cependant d'autres dispositions sont
aussi attendues par les professionnels
ainsi plusieurs articles inspirés par le
sénat qu'on sent dans le transport
routier des marchandises la marine
marchande et le transport aérien
ce projet de loi est donc complet il
permet à notre pays de respecter les
normes européennes
ils organisent et régule le transport
ferroviaire de manière pragmatique et
apporte des garanties supplémentaires
aux voyageurs
il est inscrit résolument dans nos
transports nous transporte dans pile
inscrit résolument pardon nous
transporte dans le 21e siècle avant de
terminer mon propos je tiens à remercier
bien sûr le président de la commission
de l'économie le président et maureen et
le rapporteur francis grignon qui a
rapport qui a porté avec compétence ce
projet très technique je veux souligner
monsieur le rapporteur l'excellence de
votre travail sur ce texte
je vous remercie également pour votre
grande écoute monsieur le ministre
le groupe ump soutiendra donc ce texte
avec enthousiasme et avec clairvoyance
merci
non mes chers collègues et la discussion
générale est close nous passons à la
discussion du texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire je rappelle
qu en application de l'article 42 alinéa
12 du règlement premières mains ok d'un
monde de barney recevable sauf accord du
gouvernement
deuxièmement le sénat est appelé à se
prononcer avant l'assemblée nationale
il statue par un seul vote sur
l'ensemble du texte alors sur les
articles 1 1 à 28 bis je me suis saisi
chrono qu'un amendement mais par contre
je suis saisi d'un certain nombre de
demandes de parole alors à l'article le
premier madame bernadette bourzai merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ce texte
réécrit les grandes lignes des cadres de
la perception des redevances perçues
pour l'accès et les autres prestations
autrement dit les penan les péages une
première réforme des péages de rff avait
pourtant été adopté par décret le 20
novembre dernier
mais en catimini et sans débat public
aussi je vous demande laquelle des deux
réformes était la plus importante celle
qui nous a été soumise à discussion dans
ce texte ou celle qui avait été adoptée
par décret un mois avant l'ouverture de
la discussion parlementaire
si plusieurs options faisait consensus
les modalités techniques de la réforme
vont avoir des incidences considérables
notamment pour les régions
certes le constat est partagé en 2007
les recettes des péages s'était élevé à
2,7 milliards d'euros alors que le coût
complet de l'infrastructure se montait à
civile 6,2 milliards d'euros environ par
an le décret avait entériné une réforme
des péages devenue inéluctable
les redevances sont désormais de trois
sortes la redevance d'accès la redevance
de réservation et la redevance de
circulation le problème c'est que rien
ni dans le décret ni dans le texte sur
lequel nous sommes amenés à nous
prononcer aujourd'hui ne permet de
s'assurer que la réforme préserve la
situation des collectivités et des
lignes les plus fragiles les moins
rentables en particulier dans les zones
rurales à faible densité de population
où les zones de montagne permettez moi
donc de me faire l'écho des inquiétudes
exprimées par l'association des régions
de france en avril 2008 en rappelant que
je les cite les régions ne saurait
supporter le coût de l'entretien et de
la modernisation du réseau ferré au delà
des sommes qu'elle y consacre
actuellement les régions demandent que
les modalités de financement prévoit un
mécanisme de compensation pour les
régions finançant des opérations
d'investissement qui permettent de
réduire les coûts d'entretien et un
mécanisme de péréquation qui permettent
de maintenir les lignes
à vocation d'aménagement du territoire
pour les régions la nouvelle
architecture des péages est certes moins
mauvaise que la précédente mais
l'augmentation des tarifs
couplé à une compensation réduite à
l'existant via la dotation générale de
décentralisation nous fait craindre le
pire si seulement le gouvernement avait
traduit concrètement le principe de
péréquation contenus dans la directive
2007 58 c'est eux
mais il n'en est hélas rien et voilà une
fois de plus la démonstration que ce
n'est pas entre guillemets la faute à
l'europe mais bien celle du gouvernement
national le gouvernement veut tout mais
ne se donne les moyens de rien quitte à
les faire supporter aux collectivités
territoriales et au final aux
contribuables locales et régionales
ce texte aurait pu être l'occasion
d'explorer de nouvelles pistes et vous
n'en avez rien fait alors que ce sujet
avait fait l'objet de nombreux débats
depuis plusieurs années c'est là une
occasion manquée
c'est pourquoi nous votre rencontre la
parole est à monsieur jean-claude dans
lyon merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous regrettons malgré nos appels
répétés que vous fassiez le choix
d'ouvrir à la concurrence le transport
ferroviaire de voyageurs alors même
qu'aucun bilan n'a été réalisée sur les
précédentes directives de libéralisation
nous considérons que la libéralisation
du transport de voyageurs n'est pas une
question anodine elle mérite donc mieux
qu'une lecture en urgence au sein de nos
assemblées
en effet les dispositions contenues dans
cette loi pose directement la question
du maintien d'un service public des
transports comme en témoigne votre
volonté de modifier l'intitulé de la
section 1 du chapitre 1 du titre 2 de la
loti où la notion de service public
disparaît se pose également la question
du maintien de l'opérateur public la
sncf puisque nous voyons là encore les
prémices d'un découpage de son activité
notamment avec la séparation comptable
de la gestion d'infrastructures et de
l'exploitation des services de transport
ainsi que l' isolement des gares au sein
de son activité
pour notre part nous considérons que le
modèle d'une entreprise intégrée est un
atout pour notre pays est un gage pour
la sécurité la mission de service public
confiée à la cnl sncf risque finalement
d'être menacés par cette ouverture à la
concurrence surtout si la notion de
cabotage fait l'objet d'une lecture
extensive par la raf en effet il est à
craindre que les nouveaux opérateurs ne
sont par deux lignes rentables comme
celle du tgv est que la sncf n'ayant
plus les ressources nécessaires pour
effectuer une péréquation entre les
activités rentables et celles qui le
sont moins
n'abandonne progressivement et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui est en train de se
passer pour le fret ferroviaire
les lignes jugés moins rentables une
telle dérive remettrait gravement en
cause la présence sur l'ensemble du
territoire d'une offre de transport
c'est la notion même de service public
qui serait donc mis à mal
nous sommes également perplexe quant aux
bénéfices de cette ouverture à la
concurrence pour les usagers en effet
les entreprises privées sont là pour
faire des bénéfices et ne sont pas
dépositaire de mission de service public
il faudra donc que l'offre qu'elle
propose soit suffisamment ratant
rentable pour leurs actionnaires
la concurrence risque donc de se porter
notamment sur les normes sociales pour
les personnels des entreprises et à ce
titre nous savons bien que les
mécanismes de dumping social sont
devenus monnaie courante au sein de
l'union européenne et constitue
d'ailleurs le principal avantage
concurrentiel de la route sur le rail
cette libéralisation fait également
peser des risques sur la sécurité des
usagers
en effet il est à craindre que les
nouveaux entrants ne rognent sur les
normes minimales de sécurité qu'ils
considèrent comme un coup au demeurant
nous l'avons rappelé lors de la
présentation de notre motion motion
tendant à opposer la question préalable
il est intéressant de constater la
frilosité des opérateurs privés qui
craignent de voir des normes techniques
de sécurité trop contraignantes
s'appliquer à eux et qu'ils
considéreraient comme des entraves à
leur compétitivité
on risque donc de voir les exigences de
rentabilité financière prendre le pas
sur la réponse aux besoins et à la
sécurité des circulations sur le fond et
dans l'esprit des objectifs du grenelle
de l'environnement a ajouté une
concurrence interne au rail en plus de
celle qui s'exerce avec la route n'est
pas de bonne augure pour l'émission
confièrent sncf
au vu du développement de l'offre de
transport et donc dans l'objectif du
rééquilibrage modal le groupe crc spg
propose pour sa part un autre modèle
pour une robe ferroviaire fondée sur les
coopérations l'élévation des conditions
sociales des travailleurs la sécurité
des circulations et des investissements
publics afin de développer durablement
le ferroviaire et de participer au
rééquilibrage multimodal et au maillage
territoriales l'apparent l'état madame
bariza khiari merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues cet
article premier propose d'ouvrir à la
concurrence les transports
internationaux de voyageurs aujourd'hui
la transcription que vous proposez
concerne le troisième paquet qui touche
au coeur du sujet le transport de
voyageurs avec l'ouverture à la
concurrence au 1er janvier 2010 c'est à
dire demain
toutefois depuis les premiers débats de
changements importants ont eu lieu il
modifie la loti sans même prévoir le
minimum des garanties que permettrait
pourtant d'envisager la transposition de
la directive à la lettre d'ailleurs
c'est devenu une habitude pour ce
gouvernement d'omettre de transposer les
éléments les plus intéressants des
directives européennes pour ce texte
vous avez omis de traduire les principes
de la péréquation entre les lignes
rentables et les lignes moins rentables
vous êtes fait prier pour la mise en
place du permis de conduire européen
et s'agissant de l'ouverture au trafic
voyageurs international
vous omettez d'un encadré l'exercice
d'abord la crise économique qui touche
tous les pays à assécher les finances
publiques et remis en cause le marché
qui parfois se trompent
ne vous en déplaise ensuite le règlement
européen sur les obligations de service
public adoptée le 23 octobre 2007 par le
parlement européen et le conseil modifie
sérieusement les perspectives
ce règlement a le mérite de poser la
principale question que nous devons
avoir à l'esprit avant d'examiner votre
texte comment concilier les règles de la
concurrence avec le maintien du service
public
or cette question vous ne vous la posez
pas vous libéraliser encore plus convenu
le demande
nous commençons à avoir du recul sur la
mise en concurrence de réseau avec les
télécoms le gaz l'électricité le fret
nous savons que les secteurs et services
attrayants rentable attire sans problème
les opérateurs mais aussi que dans les
zones éloignées moins denses les zones
grises
blanche personne ne se précipite il faut
de l'argent public pour réparer pour
compenser qui sur ces bancs n'a jamais
fait d'intervention pour que dans sa
circonscription
les opérateurs de téléphonie mobile ou
de haut débit desservent l'ensemble des
habitants depuis les années 80 nous
avons l'exemple même de ce qu'il ne faut
pas mettre en oeuvre dans les transports
ferrés celui de l'angleterre de madame
thatcher l'ouverture totale à la
concurrence
la privatisation avec une desserte sans
coordination a laissé un goût amer aux
usagers qui ont beaucoup souffert au
prix de la vie de certains d'entre eux
et ils on peut gagner
en effet les transports le rail en
particulier ont besoin d'une autorité
organisatrice nationales régionales ou
locales pour définir un schéma
d'ensemble
dagenais d'aménagement du territoire
avec un maillage cohérent et répondant
aux besoins des habitants y compris sur
les lignes moins rentables écrit
équilibrer les comptes par la
péréquation entre les lignes
nous sommes contre ce qui s'apparente
aujourd'hui à l' amorce d'un
démantèlement du réseau ferré c'est
pourquoi je confirme bien volontiers que
nouveau que nous voterons contre alors
pour l'article de monsieur martial
bourquin monsieur destin de la bulle a
aujourd'hui un
aujourd'hui monsieur le président tout
le monde a envie de s'intéresser au
ferroviaire et j'en suis ravi l'article
premier nous propose de consacrer par la
loi le principe de la séparation
comptable entre la gestion de
l'infrastructure et l'exploitation des
services de transport
ce contre quoi nous sommes toujours
élevé en d'autres termes la loi du 13
février 1997 qui crée réseau ferré de
france avait surtout pour objectif de
supprimer la dette la sncf pour la faire
porter au nouvel établissement
c'est pourquoi notre sens il était
impensable de dissocier l'examen du
présent texte du débat sur le système
ferroviaire français en général et sur
le bilan négatif de la réforme de 1997
en particulier le problème est que ce
débat nous ne l'avons pas eue
il a été complètement éludé le
gouvernement n'a pas souhaité que ce
débat ait lieu il serait pourtant
possible de faire de rff une filiale de
la sncf
en allemagne le gestionnaire du réseau
qui s'appelle db netz appartient à 100%
la deutsche bahn aguets société dont le
capital est détenu par l'état
un tel scénario est possible il serait
d'autant plus envisageable que le schéma
qui avait été pensé en l'absence de
toute autorité indépendante de
régulation de viande sol est le jour de
la création d'une telle autorité
aucun obstacle juridique ne s'opposerait
à une fille lisa sion d'une
filialisation pardon de rff aujourd'hui
reste que les esprits sont marquées par
des relations très compliquées entre rff
et chant gestionnaire délégué aux termes
de la loi de 1997 et de son article
premier au plus tard le 31 décembre 2008
et tous les deux ans
le gouvernement présente au parlement un
rapport sur l'évolution des relations
entre réseau ferré de france et le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure délégués à
ce jour aucun rapport ni
diffusée monsieur le ministre at il été
même rédigé un rapport qui devrait
forcer le gouvernement à se prononcer
sur une situation qu'il a lui-même créée
et dont il ne parvient pas sorti
pourtant en la matière les idées ne
manquent pas notre collègue hubert
haenel a rendu un rapport dans lequel il
propose de créer une nouvelle entreprise
qui exercerait les missions dévolues à
rff effectué par les agents sncf
le nc f or tel n'est pas notre avis il
nous semble que notre collègue est née
elle contourne le problème
il propose la création d'une filiale non
pour répondre à une stratégie
industrielle cohérente dans une logique
d'évitement des conflits sociaux
susceptibles de survenir en cas de
changement ceci étant ce dispositif en
est encore plus complexe le
fonctionnement du système ferroviaire
français
donc nous sommes bien entendu pour une
autre solution celle que j'ai décrite
précédemment
en matière sociale et à l'exception de
la mesure adoptée sur notre proposition
de créer un permis de conduire les
trains qui a été toutefois amoindries à
l'assemblée nationale ce texte
à notre sens prépare clairement
nivellement par le bas en outre je
rappelle que nous sommes opposés à
l'ouverture à la concurrence des
services internationaux de transport de
voyageurs opposés aussi parce que le
cabotage c'est-à-dire la possibilité
pour les entreprises ferroviaires
exploite un service international de
transport de voyageurs d'assurer des
dessertes intérieures nous paraît
insuffisamment encadrée et à ce sujet
l'assemblée nationale a mois encadrés
encore ce dispositif que ne l'avait fait
le sénat
voilà de nombreuses raisons pour voter
contre cet article il ya deux
poursuivants madame mireille cherche
vous avez la parole
et tout à l'heure vous avez dépassé de 5
minutes
donc enlevé quelques minutes monsieur le
président merci monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je souhaite par cette
intervention poser une nouvelle fois la
question du wagon isolé en effet que ce
soit lors de la première lecture de ce
texte ou lors de l'examen de l'article
10 du projet de loi de programmation
relatif à la mise en oeuvre du grenelle
de l'environnement
j'avais défendu deux amendements sur ce
thème d'abord j'avais proposé que l'on
inscrive à cet article 10 de cette loi
programme que le transport de
marchandises participe de l'intérêt
général et revêtent un caractère
prioritaire
relayant une partie des conclusions du
grenelle de l'environnement qui prévoit
sans aucune ambiguïté que le
développement du fret ferrer maritime et
fluvial et déclarer d'intérêt général
est inscrit dans la loi d'orientation
des transports intérieurs
le gouvernement et la commission des
affaires économiques avait en séance
publique que le 29 janvier 2009 émis des
avis défavorables sur ces amendements au
motif que ceux-ci concernaient les
wagons isolés dont nous discuterions une
semaine plus tard dans le cadre du
projet de loi relatif à l'organisation
et à la régulation des transports
ferroviaires
malheureusement lorsque j'ai posé cette
question en première lecture aucune
réponse n'a été apportée
le gouvernement a eu beau nous expliquer
que l'intérêt général n'étaient pas un
concept assez précis je continue pour ma
part de penser et je ne suis pas la
seule que la notion d'intérêt général
constitue le socle du pacte social et
que sa définition relève purement et
simplement de la puissance publique
ensuite j'avais demandé que l'on insère
toujours à l'article 10 du de la
loi-programme que la sncf reste engagé
sur le trafic ferroviaire de wagon isolé
je voulais dit maintes fois sur un
territoire comme l'auvergne par exemple
l'état catastrophique
vous venez de suivre une partie de la
lecture des conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire sur le projet de loi
relatif au transport ferroviaire tout de
suite le journal de 18h présenté ce soir
par emmanuel kessler
je vous donne rendez vous à 18h30 pour
l'examen du projet de loi sur la poste
à tout à l'heure 18h30